moi le chant a toujours été important pour
moi mais je n'ai jamais pensé que nous finirions par
chanter je serai un chanteur je pensais juste que
j'ai de la chance c'est quelque chose que je peux toujours
faire si je le veux
comme si je n'avais rien de nouveau qui
sortait à l'époque qui me
représentait vraiment la façon dont je me sentais alors j'étais
tu sais j'écris juste
j'écrirais n'importe quoi à moins que ce ne soit
directement personnel pour moi juste parce
que je ne serais pas capable de dire  l'histoire c'est vrai
je ne suis pas une fille essayant d'être une star ou
essayant d'être autre chose qu'une
musicienne quelle taille pensez-vous que vous
allez être je ne pense pas que je
vais être je l'ai dit  lui célèbre je ne pense pas que
je pourrais gérer je deviendrais probablement fou
tu sais je veux dire je devenais fou
ce serait difficile de savoir l'intérêt